aujourd'hui message de soutien pour
octobre rose vous savez octobre rose
sénat suite de dogville le vide de
glisser la vienne c'étaient les
dépistage organisé du cancer dans la
mienne sénat 17 18 17il du conseil
général de l'époque est donc évidemment
aujourd'hui tous les élus du conseil
départemental l'assemblée départementale
de la ville soutient octobre euros je
savais que anne flore iborra vice
présidente en charge de la santé voilà
le message évidemment je sensibilise et
toutes les femmes après 50 ans d'aller
se faire dépister par une mammographie
le dépistage est vite la maladie oui aux
timbres aux hawks en un mois pour y
penser à moi pour en parler autour de
vous
ce parapluie ça brise le dépistage parce
que la prévention c'est une très très
bonne a aujourd'hui pour lutter contre
ce cancer aujourd'hui quand on le cancer
et des bus est précieux
peut être guéri neuf fois sur dix ans
mesdames après 50 ans n'oubliez pas à
vos agendas prenez vous rendez vous et
d'épicés bulldozers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]